wir holen den biologen klaus stöhr dazu
uns jetzt zugeschaltet an diesem so
wichtigen donnerstagnachmittag größe
sehr herzlicher stöhr
lang es geht darum heute die welle zu
brechen dieses wort hören wir immer von
dem sächsischen ministerpräsidenten
kretschmann zum beispiel der schon
wieder heute früh von dem lockdown
gesprochen hat dort nicht nur in sachsen
sondern ja er hat das sogar bundesweit
ins spiel gebracht jetzt ist von dem
boostern als wellenbrecher die rede also
was kann die wellen brechen wenn sie
überhaupt gibt
ja also die drakonischen lotterie gehen
eigentlich immer vorbei und dem was die
realität nicht angelegt da kann man
immer nur zwischen zwei übeln wählen
sagt gibt es keinen gewinner kommt man
immer nur mit schaden aus man muss halt
nur versuchen den schaden so gering wie
möglich zu halten und man hat das ende
der pandemie nicht am anfang im auge gab
und für mich heißt das strategie
deutlichkeit von der von ganz von anfang
an und das sehen wir ja jetzt auch
blätter kontinuität der maßnahmen wenn
man das anime und am anfang im auge
gehabt hätte dann hätte man gewusst dass
die erst aufhören wenn alle antikörper
haben und wenn alle sich natürlich
immunisiert haben so wird es auch kommen
auch die geimpften müssen sich krass
infizieren bevor der impfschutz dann
richtig hält bei allen dingen die eltern
weil man hätte vielleicht auch
verstanden dass die kinder nicht
unbedingt zu den gehören die sich
infizieren müssen um zum an dem hier
dazu kommen man hätte auch gewusst hat
der impfstoff natürlich deiner kraft
verliert weil es im stoff ist ja nie so
und nur inhalte schleimhaut die
mobilität anregen die körper gebildet
und diese antikörper verschwinden das
sind proteine die von den effekt bedacht
monaten halten in der menge zurück und
die besonders
immunschwachen wir leiden darunter als
erstes es gibt eine große liste von
dingen die man wusste und lassen sie
mich noch eines sagen sie haben ja
gerade von herrn höchst besprochen und
auch die kanzlerin zitiert die jetzt mit
somatischen wochen auf die prekäre
situation hinweisen meint was für mich
vertan wird ein bisschen im alltag etwas
das man sagt dass die situation jetzt so
ist wie lesen und schlimm ist oder nicht
zu zweifeln aber man
geht nicht hinein und sieht auch die
eigene verantwortung
endlich haben die verantwortlichen in
den ländern und auch im bund aus meinem
blickwinkel die letzten drei monate auf
den händen gerissen jetzt innerhalb von
kürzester zeit die man zwar die million
menschen zu ihnen ist sicher nicht der
absolut richtige weg aber da kommt drei
monat sind wir stehen es war bekannt
dass die winter der heftig wird wir
haben ja auch bei ihnen sondern in
vielen anderen ländern haben die leute
die ein bisschen ahnung davon 18 war ja
dafür geworben sich darauf vorzubereiten
die logistik auf die reihe zu bringen
die impfzentren auch bereit zu halten in
den alten und pflegeheim die booster
impfung zu beginnen also ich weiß nicht
mehr was man mehr machen konnte für mich
hat es ein bisschen
wie haltet den dieb rufen damit keiner
merkt dass man eigentlich selbst damit
beleidigt wird aber was passiert jetzt
was jetzt passiert werden was jetzt was
hier passieren muss ist eigentlich klar
da gibt es nur rang und reihenfolge und
jetzt geht es nur noch darum dass die
parteien nicht so lange streiten
hoffentlich zu einer lösung kommen die
dann auch für die menschen da täglich am
besten ist und irgendwie ein den
anschein als strategie gibt bis zum
karrierende und welche erlösung
hersteller wäre denn das nach ihrer
einschätzung nach zweig im ganzen land
zweig plus an manchen stellen
bundesländer im komplett lockdown auch
für ungeimpfte da steht ja einiges aus
diesem werkzeugkasten wir dass sie gerne
in der politik genannt wird zur
verfügung ja also mal hier muss man
immer in der man einfach die erste und
die bedeutendste maßnahme die am meisten
sinn hätte und würde und ungefähr 50
prozent der intensivstation leer räumen
würde wäre die ungeimpften noch zu
impfen die kleine gruppe von ungefähr 15
prozent der über
erwachsenen die nicht geimpften die
geimpft werden würden dann wären 50
prozent intensivstation ja so dass er
das erste und wichtigste was man angehen
wird das zweiter ist 90 prozent der
todesfälle im letzten jahr kam es in
einem pflegeheim habe ich hier auf
ordnung schaffen wie gene
konzepte umsetzen den leuten die booster
impfung anbieten die leute fahren im
rollstuhl zur impfung prozent da muss
die hier proaktiv zu ihnen bringt mit
move logistik man muss die auch in der
stellen der mobilen pflege nimmt die
personen eine eben vor anbieten und auch
das personal wurde der mobilen pflege
als auch in der stationären pflege
versuchen zu motivieren die impfung
anzunehmen und die motivation kann ein
großes spektrum ausmachen ich bin ja
auch für überzeugung für informationen
und weniger von druck und zwang aber es
ist nicht mehr so viel zeit zum reden
auch hier hat man auf den händen
gerissen und hat gewartet bis
der topf
überkocht werden jetzt muss man
tatsächlich über diese impfpflicht für
bestimmte einrichtungen oder
berufsgruppen auch tatsächlich
nachdenken ansonsten wird man nicht
weiter kommt der nächste kommt wäre die
impfung der über 60-jährigen den booster
durchführen und natürlich die
unglaublich das ist die dritte stufe und
erst wenn man das gut auf die reihe
kriegt wird tatsächlich die 27 millionen
buchs dort und irgendwann sollte man mit
wirklicher und vehemenz auch die anderen
ins auge fassen ich befürchte dass man
über die diskussion dass man jetzt alle
so schnell wie möglich meistern wird und
vielleicht waren die kinder im
zwanzigsten mal dezember im kinder- und
dass man nie wieder vergisst das
eigentliche größte wirkung dort ist wo
man im letzten jahr strom versorgt und
ich hoffe dass das diesmal anders
erstarkt ganz schnell eine letzte frage
erwarten sie dass bald in ganz
deutschland der lockdown auch für
geimpfte kommt so wie in sachsen
ich glaube mich keine vorhersage wird
mir zu machen das sind ja alles
politische dinge was vernünftig ist
kontakte müsse reduziert werden keine
frage es macht aber regional und
dezidiert gemacht haben genauso wie man
ihn dort um das nicht die restaurants
schließen wird werden in sachsen die
zeigen kretschmann gerade dort die
intensivstationen verlaufen muss man
regional angehen und ich hoffe dass das
auch passiert deswegen kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass ein nationaler
lockdown wieder notwendig sein wird wenn
man wirklich gezielt und nach einem
stufenplan dort löscht wo es brennt und
nicht tatsächlich dann an der falschen
stelle wirklich etwas macht man auch die
leute dann wieder verschreckt mit dem
komplett locker und wo ist kleiner
erfolg danke an den virologen klaus
stöhr